[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous moi je
m'appelle Éric dunquion je suis
professeur de cinéma à 3 et je suis
aussi organisateur des mastercl donc ce
sont des programmes récurrents à raison
d'un rendez-vous de mastercl par mois
sur les différents thèmes de nos
formations à 3IS donc avec mon collègue
Thierry per des jeux vidéos
on quand on a réfléchi au programme et
au planning des masterclass très vite on
a voulu aborder le sujet de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
l'intelligence artificielle je pense
qu'on y est beaucoup soumis peut-être
qu'on tâonne avec de notre côté en tout
cas sur des fils de presse et
d'actualité on a beaucoup d'information
est-ce que c'est une information juste
ou pas et c'est une information on va
pas se mentir qui est assez anxiogène
par rapport à nos métiers créatifs que
ce soit dans le jeu vidéo ou dans les
autres métiers comme les métiers du
scénario ou plus largement du cinéma
donc on va commencer ce premier numéro
avec ce thème de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les métiers créatif et
le jeux vidéo avec notre invité Xavier
Tual merci bonjour à tous merci de me
recevoir en tout cas donc Xavier tu es
spécialiste de Lia mais pas que est-ce
que tu peux te présenter à nous en
quelques mots en quelques mots donc je
suis Xavier Tual je suis le directeur
artistique et réalisateur chez microid
Studio Paris j'ai fait une formation
traditionn
Saint-Luc illustrateur donc j'ai fait
Saint-Luc Tournet et Saint-Luc Bruxelles
voilà après je suis arrivé tout de suite
dans le dans le jeu vidéo à l'époque de
la Playstation 1 ça nous rajogit pas
voilà et puis j'ai après j'ai fait des
tours sur des plus sur du film
institutionnel des Grands Comptes j'ai
travaillé pour des grandes grandes
compagnies Audi Renault voilà et
toujours avec un
caractère
événementiel réalité virtuelle voilà
donc ils avaient toujours ce côté côté
un peu recherche et développement euh
puis après je suis revenu à mes premiers
amours qui est le jeu vidéo voilà et euh
on a j'ai travaillé là dernièrement sur
Siberia the world before qui vient de
sortir sur toutes les plateformes et
donc là j'ai j'ai j'ai rejoint Thierry
sur la dernière production donc
flashback 2 où j'apportais mon soutien
quel est ton rapport avec l'intelligence
artificielle dans nos métiers surtout
dans le jeu vidéo euh on est constamment
constamment challengé pour pour se
renouveler pour trouver des nouveaux
logiciels une nouvelle façon de produire
les images une nouvelle façon voilà de
d'aller un peu plus loin parce que la
pétence des joueurs avec les nouvelles
technologies avec les les nouvelles
consoles
euh ils veulent plus de de mon immersif
donc forcément nous derrière ça nous
challenge et on est obligé en fait de se
trouver des solutions donc souvent ce
que je dis c'est que une prod c'est
quasiment un nouveau logiciel à pris
voire deux voire trois donc forcément
quand l'intelligence artificielle arrive
on se dit de toute façon c'est une sorte
de déformation professionnelle chez nous
c'est-à-dire que on est obligé d'être ce
qu'on appelle des early adopteurs
c'estàdire qu'on va les tester on va
essayer de travailler un petit peu voilà
donc c'est un peu le Far West au début
on essaie de trouver des solutions et le
but c'est de vous dire un peu mon retour
d'expérience en prod sur l'intelligence
artificielle pour déjà commencer cette
masterclass cet échange de manière
claire peut-être qu'il est nécessaire de
définir ce qu'est l'intelligence
artificielle donc est-ce qu'on peut
artificielle d'abord dans le jeu vidéo
parce que c'est sûrement pas la même
chose ailleurs
euh l'intelligence artificielle il y a
deux aspects en fait c'est-à-dire que
l'intelligence artificielle on a le côté
dans le jeu vidéo qui est en en gros euh
comment reproduire euh les réactions
humaines de manière situationnelle
euh au début c'était des simples scripts
puis ça s'est euh complexifié avec des
algorithmes pour avoir de plus en plus
de de rapports comme si on était avec
des humains en fait en face de nous donc
ça c'est une première partie de ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un terme un peu galvodé je vous
l'accorde après l'intelligence
artificiel au cœur du jeu vidéo
maintenant ce qu'on ce qu'on commence à
mettre en place c'est ce qu'on appelle
des euh larges language model qui nous
permettent en fait euh d'avoir un
comportement encore plus fin basé sur un
algorithme qui est nourri par énormément
de bases de données et c'est ce qui va
nous permettre vous avez peut-être dû
voir passer nvida qui a qui a commencé à
mettre en place des PNJ qui avaient des
comportements assez bluffants euh parce
qu'on pouvait essayer d'aller challenger
pour essayer d'aller lui parler lui
poser des questions et il avait toujours
une sorte de comportement un peu humain
voilà et c'était assez impressionnant de
de voir ça et ça justement c'est basé
sur les nouvelles technologies donc
l'intelligence artificielle on a
vraiment deux aspects dans le jeu vidéo
c'est vraiment ce côté-là et aussi le
côté production donc on va céder de
l'intelligence artificielle pour
produire des images pour corriger le
code pour potentiellement et voilà nous
nous aider à écrire donc forcément on
est obligé de commencer à mettre en
place ces outils même si on sait très
bien que la législation court après ces
outils pour le moment donc c'est un peu
mais on est obligé de prendre le train
en marche parce que il y a bien un
moment où ils vont statuer sur ces sur
ces sur cette législation mais et on
sera à la page à ce moment-là et
aujourd'hui on l'utilise dans quel
métier le plus
souvent il a un métier en particulier
dans lequel on peut on pourrait dire on
utilise plus l'AC dans un
autre bah là pour le moment moi j'ai
envie de dire plus mon domaine dans dans
dans l'image forcément mais je suis pas
objectif mais je sais qu'il y a beaucoup
de dev qui s'en servent pour corriger
leur code donc ça ça sert énormément
donc donc je je dirais dev et dev et et
image on entend beaucoup parler de Lia
dans le domaine du cinéma aussi avec les
les comédiens et et les scénaristes on
peut-être on l'abordera en détail un
petit peu plus tard mais la question
c'est est-ce que c'est la même im Ia que
dans les jeux vidéos ou est-ce que c'est
encore des choses différentes parce
qu'on on fait des fois des fourtous avec
ce terme ah oui parce qu'en fait si vous
voulez l'a la base c'est on parle
surtout de peni qui permet en fait de
décliner les larges language model ce
qu'on appelle les large language model
mais c'est le même principe tout est
basé sur le même principe c'est-à-dire
des et c'est pourquoi ça s'est développé
maintenant puisque les puissances de
calcul nous permettent énormément de
enfin de pouvoir faire travailler ces
modèles là et derrière de pouvoir les
appliquer euh à ce que ça soit de la
vidéo du son euh de l'image du code
voilà donc et ça s'est rendu ça s'est
démocratisé les outils se sont voilà ils
se sont démocratisés et ça c'est pour ça
que maintenant tout le monde en parle
parce que il y en avait avait déjà un
petit peu avant mais c'était quand même
très rudimentaire il fallait vraiment
être un techos ENF un technicien pour
vraiment arriver à s'en servir alors à
propos de s'en servir est-ce que l'on
peut simplement en vulgarisant aussi
expliquer le fonctionnement d'une
intelligence artificielle parce que on
voit parfois des démonstrations
techniques je pense notamment à la
démonstration de Photoshop avec un spot
de pub ou avec un petit lassaut et en
écrivant un mot clé et là tout d'un coup
il y a tout qui change sur un clatement
doigt est-ce qu'on peut tu peux
expliquer plus précisément comment ça
fonctionne comment ça se nourrit et
comment après ça s'utilise en tant
qu'outil je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails vraiment technique de comment se
crée une image artificielle mais il faut
savoir que c'est plus basé sur de la
probabilité c'est d'ailleurs comme ça
qu'on reconnaît une image qui a été
créée par intelligence artificielle ou
pas c'est parce que ils peuvent arriver
à déterminer la probabilité que cette
image là a été faite par uneir
c'est-à-dire que il va aller chercher
dans ce large language model tout par
exemple quand on veut créer un chien il
va aller taper il va aller regarder tout
dans sa base de données tous les chiens
qui ont été qui ont été faits toutes les
images de chien et ils vont s'apercevoir
en fait des points de correspondance
donc forcément quand il ve créer une
image de chien il va aller taper toutes
ses points de correspondance et ça des
algorithmes peuvent déconstruire le ce
système là pour dire bah là en fait par
exemple une image a été créée à 80 % par
une intelligence artificielle donc c'est
un petit peu comme ça mais en fait si
vous voulez c'est pas vraiment très
intelligent c'est juste prédictif c'est
il va aller au plus au plus simple pour
lui au plus au plus évident voilà est-ce
que ça veut dire que lia elle est un peu
partout aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
quelque chose d'assez généraliste ah oui
oui là en fait on on a que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg avec midjourné ou
avec Open qui a fait chat GPT mais en
gros vous en avez PL Tor et c'est même
c'est même pire que ça c'est que je
pense que tous les jours tous les jours
vous avez des nouvelles IAS qui se
créent des nouveaux logiciels qui se
créent pour résoudre des des
problématiques on parlait du storyboard
on parlait du son on parlait de
l'animation faciale on parle de euh
enfin de l'animation traditionnelle de
de créer euh les alentours d'une image
par exemple image to image ce qu'on
appelle de l'image dans l'image euh donc
en fait la partie émergée de l'iceberg
c'est ce qu'on connaît mais il y en a
plein de sous sous sous domaines qui se
créent quasiment tous les jours donc euh
on va en avoir et ça infuse de partout
maintenant les moteurs de recherche vont
en avoir par exemple Bard le dernier
outil de de Google vous allez en avoir
dans vos boîtes mail vous allez en avoir
absolument partout dans les Excel moi
par exemple j'utilise Miro depuis très
longtemps maintenant il y a il y a
l'intelligence artificielle dans Miro et
ce qui va être intéressant de voir c'est
quand tout va se reconnecter les uns aux
autres en fait c'est quand il y aura un
protocole on va dire qui va fédérer tout
le monde et ça va permettre en fait de
d'avoir des synergies entre entre chaque
domaine d'intelligence artificielle mais
oui il y en a absolument partout et ça
s'infuse partout là on va se diriger
vraiment sur le sujet des jeux vidéos on
voit que ce qui ressort souvent c'est le
rapport à l'automation et là ça devient
un outil qui devient quasiment
obligatoire est-ce que tu peux nous en
parler en tant que créatif souvent on a
des martingales c'està-dire des des
petites choses sur lesquelles on se
réfugie souvent on se dit tiens ça va
marcher cet angle cette pause ce
personnage cette color MRIE bah
justement c'est exactement là où lia est
capable en fait de de nous performer
parce que elle a bien compris que voilà
la prédictibilité c'est tout ce qui est
ce qu'on appelle mainstream parce que
voilà c'est ce qui marche c'est ce qui
est c'est ce qui est c'est ce qui est
connu et c'est des petites madeleinees
de prou donc forcément lui lia va va
s'en nourrir et c'est là où elle va nous
aider c'està-dire que elle va nous
challenger là-dessus parce que ça elle
s'en débrouille très bien par contre la
gestion du risque ça elle sait pas faire
ça c'est un truc elle sait pas faire
donc dès qu'on sort de notre zone de
confort en tant que créatif dès qu'on va
pousser un peu plus loin bah le curseur
bah là souvent on a des monstres ou des
choses comme ça et c'est c'est là où où
je pense notre avenir d'Artist et de
créatif va se jouer c'est vraiment au
moment où on va sortir de nos sentiers
battus et on va aller un peu plus loin
que là ce qu'on sait faire et notre zone
de confort oui ça va avoir quelle
incidence de manière G é sur les métiers
ce
ce moi je suis convaincu que là où
l'intelligence artificielle va nous
aider c'est sur l'art accidentel moi je
suis je suis assez fan de l'art
accidental Tommy hungerer l'a très bien
théorisé et en gros si vous voulez c'est
de d'aller gratter la couche pour créer
des accidents et cet accident va être
intéressant quand on fait par exemple
des filtres sur Photoshop et qu'on fait
défiler les filtres ce qu'on avait pas
forcément prévu et hop on tombe sur
quelque chose qu'on avait pas du tout
anti iciper et c'est ça ça nous permet
de rebondir dessus et d'aller d'être
plus créatif et d'aller plus loin donc
oui ça va ça va nous aider làdessus
l'intelligence artificielle c'est que ça
va nous pousser dans nos retranchement
et tout ce qu'on faisait de manière
confortable bah va elle va s'en charger
donc on aura plus de temps pour aller
plus loin on va aborder lia dans la
création graphique tu nous as confié une
bord si on peut l'afficher avec certains
travaux qui ont été faits par euh moi
quand je vois ça je me pose la question
de comment on génère ça parce que moi je
bricole avec mjournée et cetera et et ça
donne pas du tout ce résultat donc je me
pose la question est-ce que c'est moi
qui ai pas trouvé la bonne formule dans
ce qu'on appelle les prompts
c'est-à-dire les les commandes que l'on
donne à l'a ou est-ce qu'il y a en fait
tout un travail que je soupçonne pas si
moi je suis vraiment néophite tu tu peux
nous éclairer sur cet aspect oui il y a
un apprentissage du logiciel par des
promps par des outils par des gens qui
ont testé par le fait d'aller se former
à cet outil puisque ça reste un outil
donc on se forme à cet outil euh mais il
y a pas que ça euh je voudrais alerter
en fait le sur euh c'est bien beau ces
images mais si on n'a pas l'œil critique
si on n' pas les bases d'anatomie de
perspective de couleur de voilà
d'agencement
de que sais-je euh toutes les bases
académique euh vous pouvez pas créer une
belle image
euh vous allez créer une image OK
peut-être ça va faire un peu illusion
mais vous comprendrez pas pourquoi vous
l'avez créé comment l'améliorer parce
que en fait si vous voulez là vous
arrivez à un niveau zéro et c'est à vous
après d'aller performer en fait
l'intelligence artificielle pour aller
créer tout un tas de choses et
maintenant on a de la Correction
sélective pour cré enfin pour corriger
en fait s'il y a des problèmes
d'anatomie sauf que si vous les
connaissez pas les problèmes d'anatomie
bah quand vous allez présenter un client
ou bah les gens ils vont se dire bah il
est bizarre ton personnage ouais mais
c'est joli parce que parce que tu a une
jolie lumière parce que la colorimétrie
ouais mais il est vraiment étrange ton
ton personnage donc il faut il faut bien
comprendre que sans base académique vous
pouvez pouvez pas faire grand-chose en
fait donc il faut vraiment faut vraiment
pas oublier ça c'est que le le le le
savoir académique c'est quand même le
nerf de la guerre c'est pas parce que
j'ai fait des dizaines d'années d'études
là-dedans que je veux absolument proir
ça mais parce qu'on voit tout de suite
la différence et on le voyait aussi à
l'époque quand les gens arrivaient avec
par exemple dans la 3D euh il y avait
des gens qui faisaient de la 3D mais qui
n'avaient pas de base académique et il
faisaient des jolis personnages ou voilà
ou des jolis décors et puis en fait on
s'apercevait que il il comprenait pas le
rapport d'échelle donc on avait des
marches qui faisaient je sais pas 50 cm
de haut on avait des poubelles qui
étaient trop petite enfin et en fait son
image en règle générale était plutôt on
va dire passable voilà ça faisait joli
ça faisait la blague en fait en 3D parce
que vous
mettez quelques bâtiments une lumière
avec un petit rendu euh
avec j' sais rien ver par exemple et là
tout de suite vous aviez quelque chose
d' un peu d'un peu fin mais quand vous
grattez tout de suite la couche vous
apercevez que il a pas les base
académique et ben on va avoir les mêmes
problèmes aussi avec ça donc on le voit
tout de suite maintenant quand des gens
mettent des images postent des images
sorties du tube euh quand ça enfin ça
trompe personne de voir tout de suite
que ça a été fait et pas maîtrisé donc
là je vous ai fait un petit panel
l'intérêt de ce panel là c'était pour
juste pour vous montrer euh alors déjà
ça a été fait euh en 2 jours
voilà tout ça là c'est moi qui l'ai fait
en 2 jours donc c'est juste pas possible
en fait en terme de production de
pouvoir générer ça enfin il me faudrait
enfin c'est c'est juste pas possible
quoi pour moi c'est un c'est c'est un
c'est un eldorado parce que je peux
vraiment aller tester mes idées et tout
de suite les confronter à d'autres corps
de métiers voilà moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est surtout d'avoir un
accès rapide et efficace à des idées que
j'ai dans ma tête pour pouvoir les oser
en interne et en externe parce que mon
boulot c'est ça c'est d'aller vendre des
idées euh et de déjà un éditeur pour
qu'il le finance et après quand il l'a
financé de pouvoir distribuer ça aux
autres corps de métier et qui
comprennent là où on veut en venir par
exemple le Game Director le Game
Director si je lui dis j'aimerais bien
faire j'en sais rien moi un
personnage comme ceci ou comme cela lui
va me le caractériser derrière il va me
dire voilà un personnage comment je le
vois aussi et rapidement en réunion je
peux lui faire déjà des propositions de
4 5 10 15 20 personnages et que tout de
suite on est la même finalité de la
vision et il se dit tout de suite ah non
ça il est trop dur je le voyais beaucoup
beaucoup plus rond beaucoup plus enfin
voilà donc on peut beaucoup plus
facilement arriver à un résultat et un
résultat que tout le monde enin on peut
se projeter beaucoup plus facilement
donc c'est c'est c'est pas franchement
compliqué pour faire un personnage on va
rapidement arriver à quelque chose d'
d'intéressant avec ce avec comment déjà
comment on peut faire comment on doit
commencer avec unea pour faire un bon
personnage de jeux vidéo
euh je dirais déjà le caractériser parce
que souvent la plupart des gens euh
veulent brûler les étapes mais ok ça ça
aide pas non plus on est d'accord mais
il faut déjà caractériser un personnage
euh à la base c'est l'idée en fait
l'idée faut pas l'oublier c'est une idée
c'est une envie c'est ça vient de ça
vient d'en bas euh là ce n'est qu'une on
va dire un un une étape une étape jolie
certes ok souvent on aime bien montrer
des jolies images et tout j'ai le bon
rôle hein donc euh c'est vrai que j'ai
le bon rôle au studio parce que souvent
des docs euh de game design ou des docs
de scénario parfois bon les gens alors
moi j'arrive avec mes jolies images tout
de suite c'est c'est beaucoup plus
simple à expliquer euh mais au-delà de
ça en fait il faut avoir avoir une idée
faut avoir une caractérisation faut en
discuter avec les équipes avec les gens
qui euh avec le le le scénariste voilà
avec le Game Director comment est-ce
qu'il voit le personnage de faire déjà
peut-être aussi de d'aller chercher
aussi dans nos connaissances euh des
vieux film qu'on aimait bien certains
personnages comment ils étaient
caractérisés comment il voilà
euh souvent on fait une sorte de casting
idéal c'est ça qui est génial c'est que
on se fait un casting idéal on peut
mettre n'importe quel acteur décédé ou
encore vivant qu'on qu'on qu'on rêverait
de mettre dans notre jeu et euh parce
qu'on l'a aimé dans tel ou tel film et
déjà on le caractérise après on fait du
benchmark voilà on on prend des images
du du personnage euh des photos euh ou
des extraits de film et on peut les
faire mouliner par l'intelligence
artificielle c'est-à-dire que souvent on
dit M journée avec euh des textes mais
il y a pas que du texte vous pouvez
mettre aussi des images euh vous pouvez
agjancer les images vous pouvez leur
mettre un poids ce qu'on dit une une
incidence sur le sur le sur le poids
donc moi souvent ce que je fais c'est
que je travaille peut-être avec des
images des photos mais pas que je fais
aussi des dessins que je mets aussi dans
liya que je fais mouliner et après je
mets du texte en plus ça me sort des
images ces images là je les redonne à
lia voilà le but c'est de l'emmener un
peu par la main en fait il faut savoir
quelque chose c'est que midjourné je le
considère un peu comme un un petit
enfant génial il c'est super bien
peindre mais il sait pas exactement ce
qu'il fait voilà pour lui un arbre ça
peut être un sa pleureur ça peut être
j'en sais rien moi un érable ça peut
être ce qu'il veut donc en fait il y a
un moment où quand vous allez lui dire
quelque chose ça va revenir comme un
effet boomerang si vous vous trompez ou
si vous êtes pas assez précis ou si vous
êtes pas compris si vous avez pas
compris comment fonctionne mjournée bah
c'est là où on arrive sur ah bah je
comprends pas moi je fais des promps je
fais des trucs ça veut pas faire du tout
ce que je veux et moi je fais des promps
et je j'arrive exactement là où je veux
l'amener voir même il m'emmène encore
plus loin à des choses auxquelles
j'aurais même pas pensé ou des
propositions tu te dis ah ouais
ça ça ça il y a quelque chose derrière
il y a une bonne matière et on va les
l'emmener encore plus loin et en fait
c'est ça l'intérêt c'est de créer une
synergie avec lui donc euh si vous
voulez créer avec mid journé ou avec
d'autres il faut le nourrir et il faut
le comprendre alors justement bah tu
parles de personnage mais par exemple
dans les jeux il y a des lignes de
dialogue avec des PNJ est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est convaincant euh le
résultat qu'on peut avoir dans un jeu
avec est-ce que déjà il y en a qui sont
utilisés est-ce qu'on le fait déjà un
peu oui euh est-ce que c'est convaincant
les lignes de dialogue qui sont certes
voilà pourront potentiellement être
écrits ou non en fonction de la
législation voilà ça c'est ça c'est un
sujet mais il y aura toujours une porte
dérobée parce que euh les dialogues
générés en temps réel euh basés sur des
des LLM les large language model
forcément ça va passer par de
l'intelligence artificielle I c et quand
on va voir le gap entre des personnages
de quête qui vont avoir trois lignes qui
vont se répéter au bout d'un moment et
un personnage dans lequel en fait bah
vous allez arriver de manière agressive
ou en essayant de le soudoyer ou en
essayant de minoder ou en essayant
d'être plus pushy et qui va répondre
totalement différemment qui va s'adapter
à vous et vous vous allez vous avez
l'impression en fait que c'est quasiment
un un un acteur qui qui vous parle un
acteur humain qui qui qui joue le le
rôle ça va être tellement bluffant et
nous ce qu'on voit passer ça devient de
plus en plus bluffant que ça pourra pas
tenir la route en fait face à des lignes
de script classique donc
forcément et puis en plus ça va être
amené à évoluer parce que encore une
fois tout ce que je vous dis là ça n'est
valable qu'à un instant T maintenant
euh bien mal me prendrait d'essayer de
deviner ce qui est dans le futur
maintenant ce que je vois c'est ce que
ce qu'on constate à l'heure actuelle et
le gap qu' a eu en un an an de temps
donc euh il faut bien se dire quelque
chose c'est que ok certes il y a de la
législation et tant mieux il faut qu'il
y en ait euh maintenant euh nous dans
notre domaine de compétenence forcément
comme on fait du temps réel euh bah
l'adaptabilité d'un personnage par
rapport à voilà ça va le rendre beaucoup
plus humain et forcément le le gap va
être tellement énorme que ceux qui ne
l'utilisent pas vont ils vont avoir ce
côté un peu passéiste un peu à
l'ancienne mais bon il y a il y a il y a
peut-être un public aussi pour ça mais
va avoir un vrai choc de un vrai choc
technique et est-ce qu'on l'utilise
aussi pour des par exemple la conception
de menu de de de choses comme ça
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu as des
exemples là-dessus ou pas euh oui oui
oui euh ça se faisait ça se faisait ça
se faisait pas mal euh maintenant de
toute façon euh toutes les IA maintenant
permettent de faire du du betta test
qu'on appelle du BET test c'est-à-dire
de d'aller euh euh souvent on à l'époque
voilà on prenait des des des des gentils
humains qui étaient payés à tester les
menus de savoir est-ce que c'était
intéressant est-ce que c'est intuitif
est-ce qu'on comprenait bien est-ce que
voilà machin et maintenant en fait euh
bah c'est un travail qui est un peu
laborieux euh qui est long euh qui est
pas très intéressant et forcément
maintenant les zas s'acaparent ce genre
de ce ce ce genre de compétence donc
forcément oui euh maintenant on fait les
menus par des i savoir en fait si le le
voilà le le déplacement comment comment
il a accédé en fait à différents
différents menus est qu'il a tout testé
parce qu'on on a impliqué un
comportement humain et de voir en fait
les les des travers justement d'un
joueur lambda et ça on peut le tester
des milliers et des milliers et des
milliers de fois et il faut bien savoir
quelque chose c'est que la donnée et la
grande donnée la ce qu'on appelle la
méta dononnée
c'est ce qui va nous intéresser pour
dégager des tendances parce que c'est ce
qui nous intéresse nous c'est les
tendances en fait c'est de savoir en
fait si euh bah 80 % on utilise bien le
menu ou à 60 % ou au contraire c'est
complètement à côté à 20 % et qu'est-ce
qui pourrait être amélioré lia va nous
faire des propositions pour dire bah
voilà si vous déplacez ce bouton là si
vous changez de couleur euh voilà ça
s'appelle dans le site internet ça
s'appelle le gros hacking et c'était des
tests comme ça et maintenant il y a des
a qui s'en emparent justement pour la
appliqué au site internet mais aussi au
jeux vidéo et au menu et à la navigation
en règle générale sur Internet et est-ce
que on peut extrapoler en imaginant
peut-être dans un jeu vidéo des menus
qui pourraient s'adapter à différents
joueurs différents avec des goûts
peut-être on sait qu'on peut customiser
des fois certains hub mais aller plus
loin aussi sur cet aspect là
complètement et de toute façon c'est un
peu les studios s'y mettent de plus en
plus mais c'est
l'accessibilité toutes les interfaces
maintenant vous avez des jeux pour les
daltoniens des jeux pour même des mal
voyant donc on est sur justement un
domaine qui est ultra enrichissant pour
bah pour t tous les publics quel qu'il
soit et qui puisse avoir accès au aux
jeux vidéo de la manière la plus la plus
directe possible donc oui ils vont
s'adapter et et et on aura des profils
justement pour certains types de joueurs
voire même
après on peut on peut se projeter un
petit peu dans le futur de savoir que
bah quand un joueur sur Steam ou sur le
X le XBOX GAM pass va se connecter avec
un certain type de profil bah il va il
va avoir des recommandations des jeux
qui sont adaptés en fait pour lui et les
menus quand il va arriver dessus vont
s'adapter directement à sa à sa à sa
configuration euh et même pire que ça
c'est qu'il pourrait très bien en fait
si le jeu détecte que il ne se sert pas
suffisamment de telle ou telle interface
qui pourrait lui simplifier la vie parce
que il bute sur
ou sur un boss ou si il fait pas assez
de craft ou si voilà et ben il pourra
très bien le lu suggérer de de de MRE ça
un peu plus en avant ou de le rendre un
petit peu plus accessible donc il y a il
y a il y a tout un temps un champ des
possibles en fait qui se situe à ce
niveau-là pour l'adaptabilité des des
joueurs si on veut continuer à à ouvrir
sur les sur les métiers créatifs on on
tombe sur une profession qui a très peur
de l'a sont les comédiens et
particulièrement les comédiens de
doublage parce que il y a aussi des
innovations au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle pour prendre des voix et
les traduire dans d'autres langues
est-ce que tu peux nous parler de cette
innovation et d'après toi est-ce que la
peur des comédiens est fondé
particulièrement les comédien de
doublage euh
ouais ouais ouais c'est un très gros
sujet c'est un très gros sujet parce
qu'en plus là on est avec Donald renw
qui qui qui qui fait Conrade donc c'est
un un c'est un mec génial en plus euh
c'est compliqué euh voilà il y avait il
y a Zelda aussi la fille de de Robin
Williams qui a fait une sortie là
dernièrement justement en se disant ça
faisait bizarre d'entendre la voix de
son père décédé donc je comprends enfin
quand on parle par exemple avec Donald
renw euh on s'aperçoit que il y a des
des traductions en fait ça leur prend
énormément de temps pas parce qu'en fait
ils font une traduction littéral des
choses parce que évidemment ils vont
adapter à la culture du pays dans lequel
ils traduisent des références ils vont
s'apercevoir que ça ne matche pas que
enfin forcément il y a tout un travail
et ils prennent des risques voilà moi
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'ai envie de
dire c'est prenez des risques ils vont
prendre des risques et c'est là-dessus
que le comédien aura toujours une
longueur d'avance sur l'intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence artificielle
va faire le truc bien propre voilà mais
elle va faire un truc peut-être purittin
truc un peu voilà chaud froid euh quand
un comédien va prendre le script va voir
le scénariste ils vont travailler en
doublage ils vont dire que ça ça ne va
pas cette référence là est pas bonne ça
il y a pas assez d'intention euh ça ne
caractérise pas bien le personnage ouais
mais tu es sûr parce que là on est quand
même à côté voilà non non mais on va
faire un truc cohérent et là en fait on
va s'apercevoir que le comédien a une
vraie valeur ajoutée et il est quasi
remplaçable en fait sur cette gestion du
risque alors l'autre métier euh bon même
si
l'actualité était un peu anxiogène avec
une grève des acteurs mais des
scénaristes et nous avons d'ailleurs des
étudiants en scénario dans cette salle
au premier rang donc peut-être que voilà
les inquiétudes sont en première ligne
aussi ici
euh bien il se pose des questions par
rapport à cette IA bon la grève est en
cours de résolution actuellement et en
faveur justement de des scénaristes
aussi humains mais on se pose aussi
beaucoup de questions parce qu'on on a
essayé là pour le coup chat GPT on lui
dit écris-moi une histoire en 5 actes en
trois actes et cetera il y a des choses
qui sortent est-ce que quel est ton
point de vue là-dessus est-ce que c'est
la fin des scénaristes on exagère bien
évidemment parce que on a une sensation
mais comme midjournée c'està-dire très
rapidement d'avoir un résultat est-ce
que ce résultat est bon est-ce que il
est applicable tel quel c'est ça la
question ou est-ce que ça reste un outil
comme midjournée pour les pour les
illustrateurs alors il y a deux aspects
premièrement souvent chat GPT ou mid
journé on sait pas s'en servir en fait
on s'en sert un peu à l'ancienne on
attend un résultat très rapide alors
qu'en fait comme je l'exliquer il faut
l'éduquer il faut il faut travailler
avec lui en fait c'est pour ça que
souvent quand on dit qu'on a utilisé une
intelligence artificielle c'est faux en
fait on on co-écrit ou voilà c'est un
peu une sorte de co-auteur c'est c'est
un
voilà il va il va nous nourrir et on
doit le nourrir en fait en en en en
réponse et souvent ce qu'on fait comme
erreur sur Chat GPT c'est que on va lui
faire une requête un peu à la Google
typiquement écris-moi un scénario en 5
acte alors qu'en fait non c'est pas ça
qu'il faut faire
euh déjà il faut caractériser le chat
GPT je suis un scénariste nanana de la
Nouvelle Vague donc là déjà il va
comprendre en fait que il va comprendre
il va se définir lui-même en fait avant
de pouvoir répondre à un besoin il va
devoir se définir lui-même euh donc
c'est ça qui est très intéressant avec
chat GPT c'est que souvent on a des
résultats pas terribles mais parce qu'en
fait on a des requêtes pas terribles
mais bon après les gens se disent ouais
non ça va c'est bon on a encore le temps
ouais mais non faire attention à ça euh
quand vous caractérisez en fait chat GPT
et que vous lui dites je suis un
scénariste je dois crer un scénario euh
pour quelle destination du scénario en
fait c'est pour présenter pitcher des
producteurs c'est pour convaincre une
équipe de s'enfermer 6 mois ou un an en
po prod et que sais-je pour sortir un
sombre éem film de zombie série Z donc
si vous voulez il y a ça aussi c'est
qu'il faut arriver à définir en fait
d'où il part et et quel est son but et
après il y a tout un tas de comme
n'importe quel outil comme journé ce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure c'est qu'il
y a tout un tas d'outils et de phrases
en fait un peu clé qu'il faut apprendre
comme n'importe quel logiciel qui va
permettre de challenger chatgpt pour
avoir des réponses beaucoup plus
intéressantes pour nous challenger aussi
pour nous dire euh voilà est-ce que
vraiment tu veux aller dans ce côté de
scénario là est-ce que donc en fait on
va on va se on va se faire prendre un
peu au jeu de d'avoir l'impression de de
dialoguer avec quelqu'un euh et plus on
va le nourrir plus ça sera assez
bluffant donc euh il faut faire
attention justement à euh c'est bon chat
GPT écrit vraiment des trucs pas
terribles mais au-delà de
ça pour avoir tout cette ce
conversationnel enfin cette conversation
avec chat GPT il faut avoir des bases
des bases d'écriture des bases de de
scénario faut être faut avoir de la
culture faut regarder les films faut
regarder pas que les films enfin il faut
se nourrir et il faut créer sa propre sa
propre écriture en fait et c'est et
c'est là où ça va être intéressant
c'est-à-dire que euh ce que vous pouviez
mettre des années à écrire bah là vous
pouvez l'écrire beaucoup plus rapidement
en fait et avoir des retours beaucoup
plus rapides le faire lire à d'autres
euh de voir tout de suite si ça si s'il
y a quelque chose qui prend euh donc
c'est tout à fait intéressant parce que
je le vois plus comme si vous aviez un
assistant qui écrivait avec vous et qui
vous aidait en fait à écrire alors ouais
il est un peu génial mais il est un peu
bête aussi de temps en temps donc il
faut le nourrir il faut le faut le
corriger et pour pouvoir le corriger et
B il faut savoir aussi là où on veut
aller ce qu'on veut
écrire bon on ça reste globalement
rassurant oui c'est plusut rassurant
mais en fait ce que moi j'entends c'est
que vraiment il faut qu'il y ait un
dialogue entre les deux enfin et surtout
que l'utilisateur bah il est une la
culture qu'il ait une formation des fois
traditionnelle qu'il est tout ça sinon
ça marchera pas ça marchera pas parce
qu'on sera pas on serait pas capable de
voir en fait ce qui ce qui fonctionne en
fait vous allez mettre ça dans une boîte
de Pandor vous allez secouer vous allez
avoir un joli truc que ce que vous
croyez que c'est joli vous aurez aucune
réponse quand vous allez démarcher ou
quand vous allez essayer de pitcher si
vous arrivez jusqu'au pitch les gens en
fait vont vous jeter parce qu'en fait il
y en aura 3000 scénarios comme ça
insipide absolument sans saveur parce
que et pourtant vous êtes persuadés que
c'est vachement bien et je pense que
c'est c'est pour le meilleur en fait
donc si on veut un côté positif c'est
justement vous avez beaucoup de chance
en fait d'arriver pileepoil au moment du
changement de paradigme de pouvoir en
faire d'en faire une force en fait et de
pas le subir donc c'est un outil si on
si on synthétise qui va nous aider qui
nous aider à franchir un cas peut-être
je vulgarise encore comme Photoshop est
arrivé on disait c'est la mort des
photographer non ça un outil maintenant
que tout le monde utilise et et ça n'a
pas tué le métier donc tout va bien mais
j'ai quand même l'impression que c'est
un outil très puissant qui est arrivé
euh sans qu'on soit réellement préparé
c'est arrivé un peu comme ça euh alors
la question c'est est-ce que c'est pas
un outil qui est arrivé aussi trop vite
euh à la Porée de tous sans qu'on soit
véritablement initié d'une certaine
manière c'est arrivé vite c'est arrivé
très vite euh très vite peut-être trop
vite au grand public voilà euh c'est
plus ça c'est-à-dire que euh maintenant
on seit un peu
euh on seit un peu vampirisé par les
images qu'on voit de j'en sais rien moi
le pape François en dououdoun
Balanciaga euh Macron euh dans les
manifestations enfin des trucs comme ça
donc euh souvent en fait on a nos
parents qui viennent nous voir en nous
disant ah c'est mid journée c'est le
diable et tout on va faire des fake news
et tout ça par contre nous les pros euh
forcément comme c'est arrivé quasiment
au même moment dans le grand public et
pour les pros forcément on voilà on on a
un peu de on sait pas trop sur quel pied
danser mais on essaie de rattraper ça
c'est justement pour pour ça que je suis
ici ce soir c'est aussi pour vous dire
que il y a pas que ça il y a aussi on
s'en sert vraiment pour être créatif
voilà c'est pas
juste piller le travail de de des
illustrateurs et essayer de faire des
vues sur Youtube quoi bah oui moi quand
j'entends tout ça ça me fait penser à
une période aussi
où on faisait que de la 2D on
travaillait sur des des NES des Super
NES des des Master System des Meg driv
et quand on a vu la 3D arrivver tout le
monde a eu très très peur et on s'est
dit c'est fini il y aura plus jamais de
2D terminé maintenant on va passer à la
3D on va faire de la 3D puis il y a la
Playstation qui est arrivé qui nous a
dit oui effectivement on va faire de la
3D plein de 3D puis vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui bah la 2D elle est
toujours ultra présente et même presque
encore plus on pourrait dire les les
jeux indépendants et tout ça bah ils
sont en 2D voilà il y a de la 2D ça
continue et c'est de plus en plus
performant même la 2D elle est de plus
en plus jolie de plus en plus parce que
la technique évolue mais moi je compare
souvent à ça c'est que je vois la 3D ça
a été le diable aussi quand c'est arrivé
hein mais c'est là où voilà c'était pas
au niveau du public c'était que au
niveau des professionnels cétait pas
pareil alors malgré tout
euh on pourrait parler de cadre
juridique quand même parce que si on se
réfère à nouveau à la grève des acteurs
et des scénaristes donc là un accord est
trouvé et parmi cet accord au niveau des
scénaristes c'est qu'il y ait un cadre
juridique sur la place de Liam dans
l'écriture scénaristique et l'auteur et
là ce qui est pour l'instant dans le
début de texte qui émerge c'est le fait
que surtout avec leur structure
syndicale un scénario ne pourra pourra
pas avoir cette appellation de scénario
pour être produit en studio s'il a été
intégralement ou en grande partie écrite
par un il faudra absolument que ce soit
un outil au service d'un auteur qui soit
clairement identifié donc ça c'est un
cadre qu'ils ont mis en place en tout
cas qu'ils sont en train de commencer à
mettre en place est-ce que d'après toi
c'est la bonne direction c'est-à-dire de
mettre en place des cadres juridiques
comme ça pour encadrer l'utilisation de
l'IA
obligatoirement sans cadre juridique
forcément vous allez
avoir bah
des instincts financiers qui vont
forcément prendre le pas pour se dire
comment est-ce que je fais pour produire
moins cher voilà c'est c'est pas plus
pas plus bête que ça ils sont pas
altruistes ils sont pas là pour sauver
le monde ils sont là pour voilà et et
souvent ces gens-là sont pas là pour la
beauté de l'art donc ils sont plus là
pour faire de l'argent et voilà donc
forcément eux s'ils arrivent à avoir un
coup de production moindre ils vont ils
vont ils vont ils vont s'enfner dedans
donc ça c'est obligato qui font qui a un
cadre de toute façon
il sur cet aspect là ça c'est ça c'est
une première chose sur les images généré
par exemple par M de journé faut bien
savoir quelque chose c'est
que pour le moment aux États-Unis on
peut pas déposer de copyright c'estàd
qu'il y a trois ou quatre cours là qui
sont qui ont statué donc là c'est très
simple c'est que si vous créez un
personnage par une intelligence
artificielle n'importe qui aux
États-Unis peut vous le prendre en faire
des mugs et vous pouvez pas revendiquer
en fait cette propriété en France c'est
différent en France ça s'adapte un peu à
chaque pays c'est c'est un peu une
myriade donc c'est pour ça que c'est un
peu le Far West en France c'est celui
qui a généré le l'image qui est
propriétaire de son image donc
normalement voilà c'est mais encore une
fois souvent la
législation c'est elle est comme nous en
fait c'estàd que ça a débarqué il y a un
an ils ont fait wou et ils ont pas
compris en fait ce qui s'était passer
donc forcément ils courent derrière pour
attraper leurs petits en essayant de se
dire comment est-ce que je vais faire
pour réguler tout ça de toute façon ça
va se faire dans le temps ça va il y
aura forcément des pot cassé ça va être
un peu compliqué mais oui c'est
obligatoire c'est important et ce qu'il
faudrait surtout c'est que la
législation évolue en fonction aussi de
euh bah de la technologie c'est-à-dire
que là l'intelligence artificielle ils
ont ils ont réussi à trouver un accord
là maintenant avec cette intelligence
artificielle là mais dans 6 mois ou dans
un an ça sera pas la même intelligence
artificielle ça sera pas les mêmes ça
sera peut-être beaucoup plus subtile
beaucoup plus fin comme j'expliquais
tout à l'heure euh comment arriver à
prouver que ça a été fait par une
intelligence artificielle ou pas bon il
y a du rettro engineering ce qu'on
appelle comment arriver à calculer de
savoir si une image ou pas elle est elle
est faite par une intelligence
artificielle grâce encore une fois à la
à la prédictibilité à la probabilité
donc on scanne une image et on se dit
bah tiens cette image là si il y a une
forte chance il y a 80 % de chance que
ça soit fait par par l'intelligence
artificielle après comment est-ce que
vous voulez faire puisque maintenant on
peut mixer les intelligences
artificielles c'està-dire d que je crée
un personnage je fais du concept art sur
M journée je prends cette image là je
l'envoie dans stable diffusion pour
faire du posing avec le système des
Bones puis après ce que je fais c'est
que bah je le mets dans Photoshop et
maintenant enfin c'est dans nouveau
maintenant mais avant j'utilisais donc
la beta cétait Firefly et je fais bah du
contenu génératif dans dans dans dans
Photoshop bonne chance pour savoir parce
que justement c'est c'est c'est c'est
que ça va être
multi protéiforme donc forcément ça va
être très très compliqué pour savoir ce
qui a été fait par une intelligence ou
pas voilà donc là je enfin ça ça ouvre
des pans entiers un peu vertigineux mais
en tout cas c'est bien qu'il y a un
cadre justement pour réguler un petit
peu tout ça et que ça soit pas le Far
West pendant des années et une dernière
question avant de vous donner la la
parole pour synthétiser nos échanges on
on lit et je pense que c'est une forme
de vérité même si on peut pas se
positionner comme vérité absolue que lia
va va malgré tout faire un peu de dégâts
dans certains métiers ça ça paraît
inévitable mais comme toute révolution
d'une certaine manière mais aussi que en
contrepartie c'est une technologie c'est
un outil qui va générer aussi des
emplois donc on va en perdre et on va en
gagner est-ce que d'après toi la dans le
rapport dans la balance est-ce que le
positif l' porter sur le négatif en tout
cas à cet instant alors
euh j'étais assez dubitatif voilà sur
quand j'ai j'ai j'ai un peu étudié le
truc et c'est vrai que souvent on
fonctionne très franco-français très
européen alors j'ai envie de dire oui la
balance sera équilibrée non pas que en
France c'est-à-dire que il y a beaucoup
de de compétences qui vont partir à
l'étranger parce que la législation est
plus souple parce que euh parce que les
les comment s'appelle les entreprises et
les studios qui sont capables de se
réinventer euh bah en France on est
peut-être un peu plus voilà on sera un
peu plus protégé certes mais le
changement va être un peu plus compliqué
donc ils vont se faire potentiellement
aspiré par d'autres pays donc oui il y
aura une déficit sûrement en France donc
à voir en fait est-ce qu'il faudra pas
bouger voilà aller voir d'autres pays et
et juste
prendre des compétences dans d'autres
pays revenir après créer quelque chose
aussi aussi en France parce que c'est un
peu la France qui nous a formé donc
aussi lui rendre ça donc
ouais moi ce que je vois c'est c'est que
un niveau mondial on ça va créer des
emplois plus d'emplois que ça va en
détruire maintenant au niveau
franco-français je pense
pas très bien merci on va maintenant se
tourner vers vous on va se tour tourner
aussi vers le chat de twitch donc notre
modérateur va nous rejoindre pour nous
remonter les éventuelles questions donc
je me balade dans la salle vous levez la
main si vous avez une question à poser à
notre invité bonjour moi j'avais une
question par rapport à l'impact que ça
va avoir sur
l'industrie est-ce que lia finalement va
avoir un impact surtout sur les gros
studos parce que vous parliez de prise
de risque
et je veux pas être méchant mais est-ce
que c'est pas surtout ces gros studios
là qui prennent moins de risque que les
plus modestes qui vont surtout s'en
servir ou est-ce que ça va vraiment être
très global et est-ce que le public vous
pensez va l'accepter parce que moi j'ai
l'impression que globalement il est plus
réfractaire après c'est peut-être juste
ma vision j'ai l'impression qu'il est
peut-être plus réfractaire àya donc
est-ce que le public va vraiment
accepter que au final ça soit
si prédominant dans une production c'est
une très bonne question c'est une très
bonne question euh ouais les gros
studios sont pas enfin forcément euh va
avoir un shift qui va se passer entre
les studios indépendants sur ceux qui
justement faire de la gestion de risque
et les gros studios justement qui vont
pas faire de de ça donc
euh je pense que les gros studios vont
se servir de manière un peu cachée
dissimulée des IA ils vont pas le dire
parce que il ils ont déjà eu des tolet
avec les NFT ce genre de truc donc je
pense que là maintenant les marqueteux
dans les gros studios
il ils font un peu attention avant de
pousser une nouvelle techno mais ils
vont s'en servir parce que en terme de
gain de production c'est absolument
énorme donc forcément ils vont s'en
servir mais de manière un peu dissimulée
mais ils vont pas avoir le ils vont pas
avoir le le ils vont pas vouloir aller
jusqu'au risque d'être disruptif au
point de baser tout un jeu euh sur de de
l'intelligence artificielle voilà
euh
pour en discuter avec des gens de chez
Ubi pour ne nommer queeux ils ont des
déjà à l'heure actuelle de la Red
justement pour faire des jeux sur ça
mais ça reste de la Red c'est-à-dire que
c'est c'est vraiment pas grand-chose par
rapport à ce qui dépense pour leur
triple A ils ont des bilans comptables à
défendre ils peuvent pas en fait se
permettre
euh ce genre de Shift et les seuls qui
pourront faire ça je pense euh ce sont
des petits studios d justement monter
avec voilà 4 C personnes produit par
devvolv pour nommer que autofinancer
crownfunding voilà avec avec une belle
communauté qui se qui s qui s'agrège
autour
euh mais qui a une promesse pour
l'intelligence artificielle en fait
d'être disruptif et d'apporter quelque
chose c'est ce que j'allais dire c'est
qu'en fait si vous servez de Lia pour
faire ce qui existe déjà en fait
forcément ça peut être que déceptif ça
peut être que
des des craintes de se dire ah bah vous
remplacez en fait ce qu'on fait déjà par
de la et c'est ce que j'essaie de vous
dire depuis tout à l'heure c'est qu'en
fait lia ça va nous permettre d'aller
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'on pense à
l'heure actuelle c'estàdire des jeux
auxquels vous ne penseriez même pas des
jeux avec des gameplay qui se renouvelle
quasiment
constamment qu'on n pas encore inventé
et pour ça il faut être extrêmement
disruptif faut tout repenser la chaîne
de production la chaîne de création euh
et ça aucun gros studio triple A qui met
50 ou 100 millions sur la table peut se
permettre de faire ça voilà nous avons
une nouvelle question dans le chat
twitch est-ce qu'on ne risque pas
justement de perdre la patte le style
graphique l'identité des artistes avec
les IA si c'est sur une base de données
est-ce que ça risque pas de devenir
redondant au bout d'un moment et au
contraire au lieu de sortir de leur zone
de confort les gens se limiteraient à
lia ce qui va être intéressant et oui je
l'accorde c'est que on va faire des
trucs un peu ça va s'appauvrir euh mais
la globalisation appauvri énormément de
choses et en même temps apporte quelque
chose des singularités et on s'aperçoit
que dans tous les mouvements artistiques
en fait il se crée en opposition donc
oui il y aura un certain approvissement
mais ça va créer quelque chose de
nouveau qu'on ne connaît pas qu'on voilà
et je reste persuadé que l'intelligence
artificielle de toute façon elle est
tellement nourrie euh d'éléments
disparates
que le ça crée des des accidents qui
sont hyper intéressant enfin moi
sérieusement j'ai j'ai été souvent plus
provoqué que déçu par ce que je créais
en intelligence artificielle euh alors
oui il y a des trucs mainstream je vous
ai montré des trucs mainstream du comic
des jolis décors à l'aquarelle et tout
ça mais en fait au final bah il y a
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des des des
artistes ou des artisans de
l'image bah qui le font déjà en fait qui
le font très bien mais ça révolutionne
pas le le le monde artistique voilà
alors oui on dit que c'est des artistes
ou ils font des trucs jolis ça fait des
jolies images mais bon pour moi des
artistes c'est des gens qui euh qui
provoquent qui créent quelque chose qui
ne s'est jamais vu et qui sont en
opposition qui qui apporte quelque chose
complètement
novateur et ça ça s'étudie en histoire
de l'art on s'aperçoit justement que les
artistes bah c'est des gens qui font pas
des choses au début souvent leur art est
pas reconnu c'est rare quand un artiste
est reconnu de sont vivant donc ça
prouve bien que il apporte quelque chose
de disruptif et peut-être qu'on arrive
justement à ce moment-là où on sait pas
encore ce que ça va créer mais ça va
créer quelque chose de disruptif où au
début ça sera pas accepté au début ça
sera même rejeté et après ça va devenir
la norme et puis on passera un autre
mouvement bonsoir vous avez expliqué que
pour vous servir de votre triia vous
vous servez de différentes images pour
faire une banque de données et après
vous procédez à un photashing et moi ma
question c'est comment vous faites pour
créditer les artistes les photographes
les concepts artistes les trois
d'artistes qui ont généré ces images
pour fournir la la banque de données de
de l'IA cette question elle est légitime
mais on pourrait pas les créditer en
fait tout simplement parce que ça serait
des millions et des millions de gens
accrédités puisque en fait quand on
génère une image
euh ce que vous faites comme référence
là c'est par rapport au au à la
spoliation en fait d'un style bien
particulier mais ça serait identique que
enfin là on retombe dans un domaine de
plagia c'est-à-dire de définir cette
erreur entre deux images ou entre deux
concepts pour arriver à établir le
plagia et dans ce cas-là ça peut être
fait c'est il y a juridiquement c'est
faisable mais c'est très compliqué donc
pour le moment en fait on attend une
législation à ce niveau-là et ce qui va
se passer c'est que ça va être un petit
peu je pense que ça va arriver un peu
comme un modèle à la à la Spotify ou à
la 10er et c'est pas forcément bon ça
sera bien mais ça sera pas forcément bon
c'est-à-dire que les les artistes vont
être rémunérés en fonction des écoutes
sur Spotify et ça va être la même chose
sur les bases de données c'est-à-dire
que les artistes qui vont être le plus
utilisés sur les bases de données vont
être les plus rémunérés donc en gros il
va avoir un un écart qui va se creuser
absolument énorme entre bah les grands
noms du
domaine de photographe ou les grands
artistes qui voilà qui ont déjà une
renommée internationale euh qui vont
être qui vont être dans des bases de
données et qui vont donner leur accord
euh et moi je pense que ça va être un
peu ce modèle économique là qui va être
qui va être fait mais voilà c'est c'est
un peu ma prédiction pour le moment mais
je pas je peux pas en certifier euh
bonjour donc j'avais une question
principalement parce qu'on a parlé de la
création du coup de l'IA qui aide à la
création notamment de scénario mais ici
j'aimerais parler aussi de sélection les
scénarios sont voy des producteurs qui
lisent et qui choisissent principalement
ce qu'ils vont produire est-ce que liya
pourra un jour remplacer ça choisir à la
place d'un producteur un scénario selon
un taux de je ne sais quoi oui oui yes
c'est horrible à dire mais ça va être ça
va être des modèles économiques de
Netflix qui va se dire bah voilà moi
j'ai des métadonnées je sais exactement
ce que les gens aiment regarder euh
voilà il va falloir faire sortir un
certain nombre de films de Noël sortir
un certain nombre de courtmétrage sortir
un certain g et et même et même pire que
ça c'est que euh au final on choisit
avec sa télécommande si vous êtes des
milliers et des milliers à regarder des
films un peu alternatif sombre obscur
d'un cinéma coréen un peu disruptif bah
et B tous les scénarios qui seront
validés d'un coup seront un peu dans
cette mouvance là
donc c'est on on vote avec sa
télécommande aussi c'est horrible à dire
mais s'il y a pas de public ils vont pas
aller dessus et forcément les grandes
plateformes on en revient aussi à la
dépendance euh si vous êtes tous sur
Netflix et que vous arrêtez d'aller au
cinéma d'arrêt d'essès ou aller voir
dans les festival des
court-métrages et qu'il y a plus de
public pour ça bah il y aura ça va
prouvrir la création donc c'est à vous
aussi de promouvoir votre art en fait à
emmener vos potes à leur faire découvrir
des cinémas alternatifs et pas que le
dernier Indiana Jones ou Spider-Man
voilà très bien merci à toutes et à tous
pour toutes vos questions qui ont été
bien nourries merci Xavier quand même tu
as répondu à à beaucoup d'interrogations
et bien écoutez on peut t'applaudir
quand même très
fort
vraiment merci beaucoup c'était très
éclairant et si vous pouvez garder un
peu d'énergie est-ce que vous pouvez
applaudir à tout rompre l'équipe qui est
quand même derrière la réalisation de
cette
Masterc ils ont donné le maximum
vraiment dans des conditions voilà très
très rapidees raid ils ont été très
efficaces donc merci à eux on passe le
bonjour au campus 3ies de Bordeaux Lyon
Nantes et on vous dit à bientôt voilà
pour pour un prochain rendez-vous qui va
arriver très vite et qui devra aborder
le thème du cinéma voilà merci au revoir
[Musique]
merci